اذا نذكر بان هذه الصور الان امامنا على
شاشه العربيه هي الانطلاق احتفاليه تتويج
الملك تشارلز الثالث ملكا لبريطانيا
وكما نشاهد الان هذه
العربه
مذهبه امامنا وهي طبعا
تجرها سته خيول كما نشاهد الان وهي عربه
اليوبل الماسي التي استخدمت لاول مره في
عام
2014 تجرها كما نشاهد سته
خيول امامنا على الشاشه
طبعا سيسير الموكب في موسم موكب الملك
طبعا تشارلز الثالث في جده دمول الطويله
حتى
ميدان الطرف الاغر ثم سيعبر وايتول الى
وطبعا حي الوزارات قبل الوصول الى
الكنيسه اذا نشاهد واياكم هذه الصور
المباشره لانطلاق احتفاليه تتويج الملك
تشارلز الثالث ملكاند لبريطانيا وكان قد
وصل عدد من رؤساء الدول الحكومات الاجنبيه
الوزراء ايضا ورؤساء الوزراء السابقين
افراد من العائلات الملكيه الاجنبيه
والعائله الملكيه البريطانيه الى لندن من
هناك مراسله العربيه كارينا كامل كارينا
مرحبا بك معي في هذه التغطيه بكرين كيف
يمكن وصف الاجواء حاليا المراسم الذي بدا
منها حتى الان
اجواء احتفاليه اجواء مستقره حاله تاهب
حاله ترقب لندن تستعد منذ فتره طويله لهذا
اليوم التاريخي هذا اليوم الذي لم تجده
المملكه المتحده منذ 70 عاما وبالطبع اصبح
الملك تشارلز ملكا في التاسع من سبتمبر
مباشره بعد وفاه والدته ولكن هذا هو اليوم
ربما الذي يحصل عليه على الشرعيه المطلقه
من خلال هذا الحدث الذي لديه جوانب مختلفه
اكيد هو حدث دوله حدث عسكريه ولكنه ايضا
حدث ديني فيه لحظات مهيبه فيه لحظات مقدسه
وفي غايه الخصوصيه حتى الساعه وصل الحضور
الى كنيسه ويسمسر او دير وسر نحن نتحدث عن
2300 شخص من المدعوين من بينهم 100 رئيس
دوله الكل متواجد الان تقريبا داخل هذا
الدير اعضاء الحكومه كلهم وصلوا بدات
تتوافذ الشخصيات البارزه نحن نتحدث عن
حاصلين على جائزه نوبل حاصلين على الالقاب
المختلفه الملكيه ولكن ايضا 800 من عامه
الشعب الذين ساهموا في مشروعات خيريه وفي
جهات مختلفه تابع للاسره الملكيه اضافه
طبعا الى ذلك نحن يعني لحظات تفرقنا عن
انطلاق موكب الملك تشارلز من قصر
باكينغهام متوجها الى دير من المتوقع يبدا
هذا الموكب بعد حوالي عشر دقائق من الان
ستقل العربات اليوبيل الماسي التي صنعت
لوالدته الملكه اليزابيث هذا على غير
العاده دائما او في كل الحفلات التتويج
السابقه كانت تستخدم فقط العربه الذهبيه
ولكنه فضل ان يتوجه الى دير في عربه
اليوبيلا الماسي وهي عربه اكبر حجما من
العرب الذهبيه وتم تحديثها مؤخرا واضافه
بعض كماليات التكنولوجيه اليها للتسهيل
الانتقال ولكن عند مغادرته لدير بعد
انتهاء المراسم الرسميه داخل الدير ست
العرب الذهبيه التقليديه التي نقلت كل
ملوك المملكه المتحده في يوم تتويجهم فهذا
هو ما ننتظره خلال العشر دقائق القادمه
وبعد حوالي 50 دقيقه من الان ستبدا
الفعاليات الرسميه داخل
بدايه مع دخول الادوات الملكيه ربما اخر
خطوه قبل دخول الملك تشارلز الى الكنيسه
هي الموكب خاص للادوات الملكيه الصولجان
الذي يحتوي على اكبر ماسه في العالم
قدرها او حجمها 500 قيراط كولينان
واضافه الى السيوف والخواتم والكره
الذهبيه ايضا او الكره السلطانيه كل هذه
الادوات ستدخل الى الدير يحملها اعضاء من
مجلس الوردات ومن ثم سيدخل الملك تشارلز
الى الدير هو اخر من يصل في الساعه
العاشره 53 تحديدا وكل دقيقه في فعاليات
محسوبه
طبعا الاستعداد لها بشكل دقيق خلال الايام
القليله الاخيره وطبعا منذ شهور عديده
والملك تشارلز هو الذي باشر بنفسه على كل
الاستعدادات وكل التدريبات وهو اختار كل
التفاصيل المختلفه حتى القطع الموسيقيه
يعني تم تم اختيار قطع موسيقيه محدده
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات